en karachi la ciudad más poblada de
Pakistán los mercados están llenos con
los residentes que se abastecen de
alimentos y otros suministros mientras
se preparan para que el ciclón biparjoy
toque tierra debido a la tormenta la
situación puede empeorar mucho y los
precios pueden dispararse por eso vine
aquí para comprar algunos artículos
esenciales como arroz lentejas y otras
cosas para mi familia he comprado una
lona porque hay pronóstico de Fuertes
lluvias la pondré en mi techo para
cubrir la planta baja de mi casa que
está en mal estado se pronostica que hoy
que significa desastre en bengalí llegue
como un sistema ciclónico muy Severo a
través del mar arábigo
trayendo marejada ciclónicas y Vientos
de hasta 150 kilómetros por hora en un
tramo de Costa de 325 kilómetros entre
el estado de guajarat en la India y la
provincia de zinc en Pakistán
muchas regiones de Pakistán Aún se están
recuperando de las devastaduras
inundaciones del año pasado para algunos
esta será la segunda vez en un año que
quedarán desplazados al otro lado de la
frontera en India los refugiados en este
albergue también el impacto del ciclón
en sus hogares
va a ser muy difícil si perdemos
nuestros hogares somos gente pobre
tenemos que hacer un trabajo asalariado
diario también dependemos de nuestros
animales no sé qué pasará después
[Música]
los científicos han advertido que a
medida que suben las temperaturas en el
mundo las tormentas como biparjoy se
vuelven más poderosas e impredecibles en
la India varias personas ya han muerto
debido a Los Fuertes vientos y el mar
embravecido